vous le dis donc il ya des cadeaux des
ya des cadeaux bien et il a déconné
moins bien alors je vous le dis pour
votre anniversaire tous les chroniqueurs
vont prendre une boîte sauf vous bien
sûr isabelle et dans chaque aile belge
se trouve un cadeau en rapport à qui il
ya le verre d'eau 10 à celui qui gagne
la boîte aura droit à un verre d'eau
versée sur la tête par isabelle pense
que l on prend toujours sans la tête
voilà donc voila l envie de se venger au
rni vous pouvez même le mettre sur bois
moi ça me dérange pas le doigt 10 ha
dans celui qui gagne la boîte aura droit
au petit doigt 10 ha dans son oreille sa
dette elle met souvent dans son oreille
et ça ça s'est arrêté un beau cadeau
aussi le relooking en 10 à celui qui
gagne la boîte sortira et de vranes il
va revenir déguisé en isabelle clé il ya
la danse sexy avec isa ça c'est toujours
un bonheur et j'espère que ce sera
quelqu'un de sympa il ya une journée à
la radio et qu'ils à celui qui gagne la
boîte passera une journée rtl et
qu'isabelle de 5 heures à 18h30
ça c'est une bonne talent à l'euro 12 ou
celui qui gueule la boîte remporté un
massage en direct et en duo avec
isabelle et oui ça aussi c'est une bonne
danas une panacotta métisse à nantes
devra manger une panacotta dès qu'ils
avaient n'avait qu'une seule cuillère
c'est pas le méga smac 10 à celui qui
gagne la boîte devra ce maquis isabelle
pendant 10 secondes c'est des vrais ce
match là on est en
la personne
ouais alors voulez-vous la une la hutte
allait très bien merci médailles 20 à 5
la cei ne s'est pas non plus
quelques-unes qui soumet les beaux
cadeaux et son webos la 8e année c'est
quoi laquelle mathieu l'a4 la callas les
voit pas de base pour échanger s'il vous
plaît respectez ça c'est son
anniversaire il ya des trucs maxime la
5e but un peu bête un voyage à ibiza
refait tout cas c'est bien ca passé de
la 2e à cette boîte ou pas et c'est
parti est bas plus tout ce que veut nous
avons démarré pas bon alors il a pris la
6 cela précise sont là dès mardi à
charge et vous avez pas les bains c'est
quoi ces directs pour toi c'est le verre
d'eau disent ah
[Applaudissements]
envie de le faire alors envie de le
faire à la baisse plus avec le mesh à ça
revient enfin à lui bien alors il lui
est arrivé et m'a bien qui ce qu'il ou
encore je viens moi
est-ce que c'est peut-être comme ce très
beau frère un téléspectateur entendu les
téléspectateurs ne gagne pas les mêmes
qu'à l'aube et revenir à temps selon la
sec
qu'est ce que ça va être de quoi il en
vit une petite danse sexy c'est le tout
- dana sera alors à oui il faut s'en
tenir
y'a pas encore le smad c'est le roux de
[Applaudissements]
le massage à deux isabelle et et laxisme
dont je remercie allah dit aller
[Applaudissements]
j'ai les boules
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est bien il ya cammas a alors
celle là demain
[Applaudissements]
alors allez vous voulez alors même
étonnant autant ce ben oui mobile edge
ramassage c'est vrai mais toi d'autres
chances ouais alors soufflé jean michel
maes et isa et vous vous occupez les
coûts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
kitty fla c'est très bien merci merci
et comme il est beau regarder comme il
connaît bravo sofiane scheme for sale et
j'adore aller merci merci à regarder et
vous avez vu elles sont gérées fait sur
jean michel rey ferme à maxime très bien
je me suis remise artery géraldine
maillet sera pas que son nez dans
l'anniversaire dire isabelle morini bosc
est un cadeau pour chacun un cadeau
ampute un jour à ce qu'est ce qui se
passe ce pas le cadeau j'aurais pas aimé
avoir celui-là ça y est c'est fini
abdellah pas dakota pas d'à côté mais
bon attention c'est le total des
produits
oui la panna cotta avait cueilli hier
c'est une cuillère de la boutonné une
cuillère gel mois attention c'est pas
parce que je mange avec les doigts
là bas c'est encore plus et ce à quoi
nos noms et adresses comment comment 6
et comme maintenant elle commence
isabelle commencé son univers c'est
normal allez-y huawei il venait
d'ailleurs ces candidats
mais quoi
bah oui autant de vos cadeaux et
isabelle pour l'instant jusqu'à là tout
va très bien on devrait bien attention
allez on va passer aux cadeaux 1 allée
de castagniccia est-ce que je peux moi
c'est mon papa avant c'est aussi
l'anniversaire aujourd'hui je suis au
meilleur rebondeur son anniversaire du
palier j'ai pas bon c'est pas qu'ils
viennent pas passer à l'essieu khatami
c'est votre affaire banale sylvain
caillot 22 la panna cotta et radio par
les votants fac et je l'adoré ton père
tu es rule à dornach vraiment toi c'est
normal ce ton père
il adore alors attendez il change pas
non plus il peut pas changer
qui parlait du cochon
chouette je vais parfois par par
tradition je prends la boîte de matthieu
bataille ne sais pas si vous êtes en
colère çà utoya qua non j'ai pas bien ah
non je te jure je ne pourrais pas tenir
les inquiète pas il a rappelé sur canal
alors tu prends la caboche pour aller tu
prends la cape à cenon
[ __ ] une jaune à la radio des quotas
ont bien qu'ils comptaient que tu
sortiras si c'était ta tata a lobé d'al
jarida ils vont voir ce qu'elle gagne je
suis fier papa de manon fenocchio pour
échanger soul je ne vois tu as peut-être
d'avoir su fait l'ag patrick cevaer le
tri cet ancien sait si c'est ouvert a
dit richard alors allez tous nos vins
avec isa mois de noisy offre 7 comme des
toiles à tout va mais pourquoi tu dis ça
chez ton ami oui tu pense qu'il faut que
je fasse quoi aucune barre non mais non
mais où ça allez vas-y et sur quoi allez
soyons fous c'est rien l'organisation
vous fait quoi et tu vas le faire
pendant la pub pour 10kg inquiète pas
aller sur maintenant ça devient très
violent là
voilà ok je change est trop tard il est
le roi des changements je peux faire
mettre la grande guerre aux usa il reste
le doi 10 ha dans la danse sexy avec isa
ou le méga ce mardi s'est achevée la
danse alors qu'elle y est ce que vous
gardez votre boîte nuire aux mares mac
et 11 mai mais moi je vais la garder
je suis sur ma boîte vous gardez semble
sûr c'est sûr oui certaines certaines
kelly le doi 10 à daloa il de pire
visage et il a les quotas celui-ci pas
trop prononcée sauf celles un petit lob
et l'autre et l'autre
et oui m'a fait mal c'est juste super
désagréable mais l'histoire
lorsque dont les deux frères ennemis
jean michel mr bah de jeu de l'ange tu
es allé voir quelqu'un a essayé de me la
voler vida cadreur excusez moi pas de
mal alors les salles
alors attention j'ai laraque numéro une
mathieu il reste le méga sous mac 10 à
un chant et la danse sexy n'ont pas
beaucoup changé fil avec ton petit air
ont changé si l os mac
ouais un conseil condamne 10eme la 85e
vont me saouler allez vous savez quoi
donc là il reste ou de la doré c'est
jean-michel il est inerte de la corse et
que c'est avec isa alors donc ici il
n'ya pas là dedans c'est que c'est ici
c'est que l'os mac et là jean michel
maire de troyes l'attend cette série
[Applaudissements]
alors
les sages
on prend les matches les uns après les
autres déjà isabelle et jean michel la
danse sexy
[Applaudissements]
il
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c
quand ils sont montés bel anniversaire
c'est bon bravo mais très vite soit on y
va c'est pas ça ça s'est passé à san
mamés isabelle et mathieu quand l'amour
tapas votre pompe avoir un chronomètre
mais je veux la bouche contre la bouche
pendant les lycées jeanne neige pourrait
faire ça mais on a tous voila matière
des plus de 45 ans
c'est ma faute j'aurais pu rêver
attention les chéris avec la gueule on a
maintenant mais merde tu seconde avec un
peu de langues ah oui une longue et je
fais toutes les émissions gratuitement
dans un monde je vais voir des fans je
vis dans une attaque qui sont des pays
amis sur nous qu'est ce que tu veux
actuellement 17 et isabelle a gagné pour
son anniversaire un smack langoureux
seconde avec voiture rascal oui mais
chéri on a le roi de la mauricie mettre
une musique que l'on a presque à l'aube
il faut est-ce que je boive a dit on à
khaled ça aurait dit non ça c'est satan
l'événement c'est paladares et c'est bon
la voilà tu en as pascal obispo pascal
est ce que tu peux nous faire un petit
truc à la guitare ou au piano je t'ai
mis un petit peu c'est une chanson
d'amour
si moi je sais pas ce que tu veux je te
fasse belle envie d'aimer envie d'aimer
en live et là à mon top cet automne à
son fils et à un moment je ferai comme
ça comme julien combes et danseuses au
cannabis alors les mecs et faites ce que
vous voulez mais fait le mien désire
arrêter son anniversaire et anniversaire
de la femme voilée ce sera
c'est très très près attendez attendez
avocat je vous ferai comme ça
j'ai beaucoup de moi je suis riche
seigneur soit quatre coups sûrs témoin
ce soit
[Musique]
je n'en
pourquoi
quant à partager
m
oui
[Musique]
on vit
j'aimais
[Applaudissements]
remarquez pas très bien c'était très
agréable
c'est la vie c'est grand c'est grave
alors là c'est à la cgrae c'était bon
hammami ami e s que tu veux tout ce qui
dépasse et c'est pas le dentier c'était
bien moi je vais me dont toi ok ça
prouve à quel point on est proche dans
cette famille là là